The European Union has decided that what
Europe really needs right now, while
it's dealing with economic stagnation,
mass illegal immigration, rising crime,
and cultural collapse, is to spend 10
million euros of taxpayer money
promoting fake history. Not the usual
fake history either, where a nation
tries to puff up its own past. No, the
EU is funding a kind of revisionism that
actively undermines Europe's cultural
confidence. History rewritten in the
name of diversity. the same diversity
that's tearing the continent apart. This
program is called the European Quran,
and its main goal is to convince
Europeans that Islam and the Quran were
foundational to European civilization.
The project proudly claims it will quote
challenge traditional ideas about the
Quran and European identity. How? With
exhibitions, conferences, and glossy
books. In other words, a propaganda
blitz funded by Brussels. Because
apparently there is no better use of€ 10
million euros than teaching Europeans
that the Quran was never a foreign
invader's manual, but a misunderstood
spiritual sibling of Europe's own
traditions. According to the European
Quran's website, the project covers the
years 1150 to 1850 and includes
everything from Spain to Hungary. It
claims that quote, "The influence of
Islam on European culture is greatly
underestimated." So, is that true? Well,
yes, if you include centuries of war,
conquest, slavery, and terror as
influence. Historian Bernard Lewis, not
exactly a right-wing zealot, put it like
this.
In one of his books, he wrote, quote,
"We tend nowadays to forget that for
approximately a thousand years, from the
advent of Islam in the 7th century until
the second siege of Vienna in 1683,
Christian Europe was under constant
threat from Islam. the double threat of
conquest and conversion. Most of the new
Muslim domains were rested from
Christendom. Syria, Palestine, Egypt,
and North Africa were all Christian
countries, no less, indeed rather more
than Spain and Sicily. All this left a
deep sense of loss and a deep fear.
Another historian, Franco Cardini, puts
it even more bluntly in his aptly titled
book, Europe and Islam. He writes,
quote, "If we ask ourselves how and when
the modern notion of Europe and the
European identity was born, we realize
the extent to which Islam was a factor,
albeit a negative one, in its creation.
Repeated Muslim aggression against
Europe was a violent midwife to Europe.
So yes, Islam influenced Europe, but not
by inspiring Renaissance art or
enlightenment ideas. It influenced
Europe by trying to destroy it. But the
European Quran program doesn't seem to
care about that distinction. It sees no
difference between influence and
intrusion, between contribution and
conquest. What Islam brought to Europe
was a religious system that from its
founding text, the Quran, gave
non-Muslims three options: convert,
submit, or die. See Quran 929 and 95 and
others. That's not cultural fusion.
That's theological warfare. But now,
courtesy of the EU's larges, we're told
that the Quran, once rightly viewed by
Christian Europe as the ideological
manual behind jihad and conquest,
was actually an integral part of
European identity all along. Quite the
contrary, from the very start, Europeans
have shown only contempt for the
teachings of the Quran, that quote most
pitiful and most inept little book of
the Arab Muhammad to quote the 9th
century's nicotist Bzantios. After
studying Islam's holy book, he concluded
that it is quote full of blasphemies
against the most high with all its ugly
and vulgar filth. Particularly, its
claim that heaven amounted to a quote
sexual brothel. He wasn't alone. For
centuries, European scholars translated
the Quran not to admire it, but to
understand and fight the ideology behind
it. Christians studied Islam because
they had to defend their civilizations
from it. And even the European Quran
admits that its agenda goes beyond
history. On its own website, it states,
quote, "Our project is addressing
pressing and current issues in Europe
and promises to open new perspectives on
our multi-religious societies."
Translation: This isn't just about the
past. It's about reshaping the present.
It's about social engineering, trying to
convince Europeans that Islam has always
belonged there. And if you think
otherwise, well, you clearly haven't
been to their exhibitions yet. One brave
EU politician came out and said it. This
is a blatant rewriting of Europe's
religious and cultural history. He
called it what it is, falsification,
financed with your money. But it gets
worse. Some of the European Quran's
researchers are openly tied to political
Islam, specifically the Muslim
Brotherhood. One even wrote a glowing
biography of the Brotherhood's founder.
And multiple academics working on the
project are reportedly close to the
group. another researcher who spent
years exposing how Islamist ideologues
have infiltrated Europe's universities
and institutions. She's now being
punished for telling the truth. What's
the message? Simple. If you expose the
Islamic ideological push behind these
academic projects, you're the problem.
And then there's John Tolen, one of the
European Quran's key scholars. He claims
he's just trying to study Islam
scientifically. He says his work is
meant to counter Islamic radicalism. But
if that were true, shouldn't he be
trying to convince Muslims to read the
Quran differently? Instead, he's focused
on convincing Europeans that the Quran
is just misunderstood and that there are
multiple ways to interpret it and that
we've just been reading it the wrong way
for centuries. But this isn't
surprising. A major theme in his work is
defending Islam and attacking Christian
voices who resisted it. For example, in
one of his books, which I have right
here, Sariss's Islam in the medieval
Islam in the medieval European
Imagination, he recounts how dozens of
Christians were imprisoned, tortured,
and executed in Muslim Cordoba for
refusing to convert, known as the
martyrs of Cordoba, about 50 of them.
But rather than condemn the Muslim
executioners, he criticizes the martyrs,
especially St. Ulius, who mocked
Muhammad for claiming he would deflower
the Virgin Mary in heaven. Tolen calls
that a lie, an invention meant to shock
Christian readers. He accuses Eulogius
of trying to stir up hatred. But here's
the truth. That claim isn't a lie. It
comes directly from Islam's own sources,
including a hadith where Muhammad is
promised Mary as his wife in paradise.
So it wasn't Eulogius making up
blasphemy. It was Muhammad making a
blasphemous claim and modern scholars
ignoring it because it ruins their
narrative. And that's the real goal of
this whole project, to erase Europe's
memory of Islamic conquest and hostility
and replace it with a fantasy of
peaceful coexistence. To turn the Quran
into a misunderstood spiritual guide to
make Islam look like it was always a
central part of Europe's identity. It's
not history. It's not scholarship. It's
propaganda dressed up in academic robes
paid for by the EU and pushed by people
who want to reshape Europe's identity
from the ground up. The goal isn't to
uncover forgotten truths. It's to create
a new narrative, a fake history where
Islam has always belonged. Where
centuries of bloodshed and persecution
are rebranded as cultural exchange. So
yes, the European Union is paying
generously, not to preserve Europe's
heritage, but to dismantle it. And
they're doing it not with invasions, but
with exhibitions, not with violence, but
with peer-reviewed papers, quiet,
sanctioned, funded. If that feels like a
betrayal, that's because it is. And the
real question is, how many more blatant
betrayals will it take before Europe
wakes up and pushes